some ordered pairs for a linear function
of x of x are given in the table below
which equation was used to generate this
table so they give us a bunch of data
points when x is 4 y is negative 8 when
x is 7 y is negative 20. so on and so
forth and then it was
this these points have been generated by
one of these equations right over here
so let's just see which of these
equations actually could have generated
all of these points so let's go to this
first point right over here 4 comma
negative 8. let's go equation by
equation if x is 4 here negative 2 times
4 would be negative 8. let me just write
down negative 2
times 4
we'd multiply negative 2 times 4 to get
negative 8 and then i would add 1 to get
negative 7 i would get negative 7. so
for this equation when x is
y would be negative 7 not negative 8. so
this equation definitely did not
generate this top point right over here
so we could just rule it out whatever
equation should have been able to
generate for any given x for any of
these x's should generate this y right
over here
now let's go to this next equation y is
equal to negative 2x plus zero so when x
is 4
y would be negative 2 times 4 which is
negative 8. so the second equation seems
to be capable of generating this first
set of points when x is 4 y is negative
8. let's see if it works for the second
one right over here when x is 7 you
would have negative 2 times 7 which is
negative 14. but here when x is 7 y is
negative 20. so this one we can rule out
because when x is 7 y does not equal
negative 20 like this point right over
here so we'll rule that second one out
now let's look at this third one y is
equal to negative 4x plus 8. well we
could go to this first point again
when x is 4 let's think about what
happens when x is 4. so when x is 4 you
have negative 4 times when you have
negative 4 times 4 which is negative 16
plus 8 which is negative 8. so it seems
to it seems to be able to generate this
first point when x is 4 y is negative 8
for this equation right over here now
let's see when what happens when x is 7.
so negative 4 times 7
is negative 28
negative 28 plus 8 is negative 20. so
this candidate is starting to look
pretty good is pretty good it satisfies
these two points and frankly for any of
these linear functions if it satisfies
any of these two points if if some
linear function generated all of these
if some function satisf can generate any
two of them it'll probably status or it
will satisfy all of these because two
points define a line but we can verify
it right over here so let's see what
happens when x equals eight
negative 4 times 8 is negative 32
plus 8 is negative 24. so that satisfies
so that when x is 8 y does equal
negative 24. and then finally let's look
at that last that last point
when x is 9 negative 4 times 9 is
negative 36
plus 8 is equal to negative 28 and
that's exactly what we see here in this
table so we don't even have to look any
further choice 3 satisfies satisfies the
conditions that when x is any one of
these things the corresponding y that's
defined by this by this equation is
going to be is when x is 4 y is negative
8 when x is 7 y is negative 20 so on and
so forth